[Music]  I thought we were your mother  trampolining  superheroes are illegal you want to  fight bad guys defines Who I am  we're not saying you have what someone  on TV said I was approached by this  tycoon most to talk about hero stuff  help me bring supers back into the  sunlight  we need Elastigirl  [Music]  it's no problem not the way you're  supposed to do a dad they want to do it  I don't know that way why would they  change math over Dusseldorf do those are  dog housing Kyle s so heavy  troop he closing I could have done this  if you hadn't taken over so well I've  got to succeed so she can succeed  bob is tricky but I can't keep giving if  done properly parenting is a heroic  action done properly  [Music]